[Música]
jueves una sección que me pone muy feliz
revista de prensa con rosa pérez masdéu
mi querida amiga rosa vamos a empezar
entonces abriendo y haciendo un repaso
por todos los titulares franceses
empezamos con le monde libération le
figaro y mediapart buenos días raúl
exactamente vamos a ver como titula la
prensa francesa ya en esta cuenta atrás
de cara a la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales vemos como el
mont dice presidencial los riesgos de
una elección incierta y entre los
riesgos destaca pues que hay personas
desconocidas para la población general
entre los los aspirantes a la
presidencia francesa por otro lado que
marine lepén vuelva a estar por segunda
vez consecutiva según los últimos
sondeos en la segunda vuelta
presidencial y una alta abstención no
que se prevé de cara a la votación de
este domingo
por otro lado liberación titula extrema
derecha más que nunca un peligro y dice
desde habilitada en la opinión pública
marín lepén surfea sobre una dinámica
todavía más favorable que en 2017 lo que
ya a poner nervioso al propio macrón
según liberación y en ese sentido le
figaro titula precisamente una
entrevista con el presidente candidato y
manuel macrón en la que destaca la
siguiente cita la crisis las crisis me
han forjado mi energía está intacta pero
por otro lado en otro artículo de este
periódico de luz figaro que es amplia
abiertamente de derechas pues alerta no
de la estrategia que ha seguido macrón
de dar por hecho que él va a estar en la
segunda vuelta presidencial junto con a
marín lópez no y de presentarse como una
barrera a la extrema derecha como ya
hizo en 2017 pero dicen eso conlleva que
marín lepén a diferencia de los otros
candidatos no necesita presentaciones
todos hablan de ella y destacamos raúl
lo que comentábamos hace un rato y es
que en el spot electoral marín depende
dica gran parte del tiempo más que nada
a convencer a los electores que que
podrían abstenerse de la importancia de
ir a votar más que no a defender pues su
propio programa que tal y como titula
mediapart el proyecto presidencia marín
le pen pizza los derechos fundamentales
con un programa xenófobo y autoritario y
en otro artículo de este medio también
de mediapart dicen macro macrón llama a
apaval a pagar no las brasas que él
mismo ha avivado pues en relación a esto
no al peligro de la extrema derecha así
ese rosa ahora vamos a ver entonces las
caricaturas de mediapart y libres yo me
encantan las películas las caricaturas
también en épocas electorales no rosa
exactamente empezamos por mediapart con
un dibujo de cie que dice el primer
abstencionista de francia y vemos pues a
emanuel macro que pasa de participar en
los debates electorales previos a esta
primera vuelta presidencial y por otro
lado vemos un dibujo de coco en
liberación en los que plantea pues tanto
a emanuel macrón como a marie le pen
como a pues a jean luc mélenchon el
candidato de la francia insumisa aquí
peleándose por haber quien llega en las
dos primeras post posiciones de esta
primera vuelta presidencial para pasar a
la segunda si es rosa y cerramos
entonces comentamos comentando como los
medios de comunicación han participado
del debate público que hago forma esta
campaña empezamos viendo un análisis de
crimen efectivamente porque acremente es
un observatorio que monitorea los medios
de comunicación y a principios de este
año de 2022 analizaba como en la segunda
mitad del 2021 los principales medios de
comunicación de francia habían hablado o
no qué protagonismo le habían dado a los
distintos aspirantes al elíseo y lo que
vemos es que sobre todo en los programas
matinales de radio como en los
noticieros de la noche así como en las
cadenas de información en continuo se da
una bueno se dio en ese momento el que
no estaba regulado pues la la forma en
la cantidad de tiempo que se da a cada
aspirante como sí lo está en tiempos de
campaña vemos que se le daba un gran
protagonismo pues hacemos al open a
macro pero macro pues puede ser más
lógico porque también es el presidente
es lógico que haya muchas noticias en
referencia a él no mientras que las
menciones
izquierda solo ocuparon un 16% de las
menciones que se hizo a los candidatos
en las televisiones de información en
continuo un 22 por ciento de las
menciones en los noticieros y un 21% en
las matinales de radio y cerramos
entonces un artículo de aldo ruber
publicado en agenda pública del país a
principios del año rosa pero que está
más vigente que nunca y nos ayuda a
entender el panorama político de francia
de cara a estas elecciones exacto es un
análisis con mucha profundidad lo vamos
a resumir para ya pasar a la entrevista
y lo que dice es que es evidente que hay
una derechización del debate público
mediático en francia pero que eso no
responde a una derechización de la
sociedad da como ejemplo que las en los
apoyos populares a las ideas de extrema
derecha del frente nacional llamado hoy
en día agrupación nacional son hoy en
día igual que en 1984 de un 26 por
ciento que por otro lado este mandato de
macrón estos cinco años han estado
protagonizados por movimientos sociales
que han puesto en el centro del debate
como amarillos las cuestiones de
justicia social dejando de lado las
cuestiones más identitarias que
protagonizan el debate público que lo
que sí es destacable es una crisis de
representatividad que afecta más a la
izquierda que a la derecha que la
derecha pues mantiene la fidelidad de
los electores de mayor edad y de las
clases superiores y que por lo tanto es
más justo más justo hablar de decís
quier diz acción electoral por
desmovilización que de de derechización
bueno rosa le pido entonces que se quede
conmigo para dar paso a nuestra primera
invitada del día sobre este tema por
supuesto